Often both natural languages and programming languages
have optional parts that don't have to appear in every utterance.
For example, "I think" is a totally valid sentence,
but so is "I think correctly," where we've added the adverb "correctly"
that modified the verb "think."
You don't need to do this, though.
You can leave it out. The sentence on the left is perfectly fine.
We're going to want to represent this optional construction,
this optional adverb, in our formal grammar.
Here on the bottom half of the screen
I've drawn a slightly more complicated grammar.
Sentence goes to optional adjective, subject, verb.
Subject and verb work a lot like they did before.
This time our subjects are either William or Tell,
and our verb is either shoots or bows.
But our optional adjective can either be the adjective "accurate"
or it can be nothing.
It disappears.
We can either leave this blank, or if you like,
we could write that same epsilon we used to have there
when we were talking about finite state machines
that means the empty string or no input.
Looking at this grammar, I have a quiz for you.
Fill in the blank.
Starting from sentence, how many valid utterances are there?
How many strings can we make in this language?
How many different things can this formal grammar produce?